bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte les
producteurs en serre les réclamaient
depuis des années et cette fois ci sera
peut-être la bonne
cet été hydro québec a déposé une
demande officielle auprès de la régie de
l'énergie pour que des tarifs
préférentiels d'hydroélectricité soit
octroyée pour chauffer et éclairer les
serres les tarifs pour tous les
producteurs pas seulement les gros on
veut ainsi augmenter l'autosuffisance
alimentaire du québec
mais certaines questions demeurent en
suspens
[Musique]
des parties d'un petit jardin familial
dans le four de 1000 pieds carrés parce
qu'isabelle le jardin bosso
m'intéressait pas du tout je renseigne à
ce moment là enfin vous êtes dedans ça
commence à nous intéresse en plus en
plus on est tombé un peu dans le
maraîchage bio intensifs
depuis quatre ans la ferme le pied
maraîchers connaît une croissance
fulgurante
elle est passée de 25 à 300 paniers de
légumes hebdomadaire une croissance
impossible sans une serre peuvent
occuper celui ci nous sommes au mois
d'août geneviève et isabelle viennent de
recevoir la livraison de leur deuxième
serre en pièces détachées pour réduire
les dépenses elles la montre ont
elles-mêmes
au fond pourquoi vous coup de chance
pour chauffer leur serre elles ont pu
mettre la main sur des fournaises
usagers à un prix dérisoire et fournaise
au mazout par l'installation complète
avec les tuyaux de cuivre les raccords
et tout ça va peut-être coûté 500 $
montella ça ici puis j'ai deux formats
sd alors comprend pas s'arrêter oui le
mazout et mais presque deux fois plus de
gaz à effet de serre que le propane qui
n'en demeure pas moins polluants mais
pour les deux maraîchers ce système là
comporte un avantage pour mes autres ça
peut confère la plomberie on est capable
de le faire parce que c'est pour nous
c'est essentiel à quelque part de faire
le maximum qu'on peut qu'on va chercher
l'expertisé seulement quand c'est
nécessaire
les marges étant mince en agriculture
chaque petite économie compte où il peut
être que c'est contestable de faire des
légumes bio avec du mazout mais bon il
ses choix qu'on a fait présentement dans
des cités le mazout c'est comme une
étape avant de penser à autre chose même
pour partir rentabiliser le truc c'est
déjà une très bonne option
et qu'en est-il de l'hydroélectricité
après tout le québec est la province
championne de cette source d'énergie
propre et renouvelable
quand un fort chez les fournisseurs le
four days puis concert ils vont orienter
tout de suite vers le propulser le
réseau type usa mal d'options c'est plus
que le vieil option au piquant à la
chance d'être des vieux système tant
mieux mais sinon c'est vraiment
l'électrique est jamais mentionné trou
mais cette situation pourrait-elle
changer en juillet hydro québec a
annoncé sa volonté de rendre
l'électricité plus accessibles à tous
les producteurs en serre on parle de
plus de 1000 producteurs on parle d'un
chiffre de 5 points 59 sous le
kilowattheure qui évidemment très
compétitif avec les autres formes
d'énergie mais aussi qui est un rabais
substantiel par rapport au tarif moyen
aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient sous le
kilowattheure audrey yank est ingénieur
spécialisé en énergie elle a tout de
suite vu les effets de cette nouvelle
lame ans de québec pour le nouveau tarif
pour le chauffage des serres suscité
beaucoup d'intérêt parce qu'un coup
producteurs qui ont vu une possibilité
des réduire leurs coûts énergétiques
le nouveau tarif proposé pour chauffer
les serres est avantageux par rapport au
mazout et au propane
mais l'électricité demeurera tout de
même beaucoup plus cher que le gaz
naturel et la biomasse
l'annoncé nouveaux tarifs d'électricité
est un bon premier pas pour réduire
l'impact carbone le secteur des sarts au
québec mais ça sera pas assez pour créer
une réelle tension danger tic puisque on
a encore le gaz naturel qui est à plus
faible coût
au québec les grands producteurs
chou-fleur sert au gaz naturel ou à la
biomasse
deux sources d'énergie plus abordable ce
n'est donc pas à eux que se destine les
nouveaux tarifs
la transforme en l'électricité va valoir
la peine pour des entreprises dont la
facture énergétique est élevé avec le
propane ou le mazout ou et pour des
entreprises sont vraiment qu'un est là
la réduction de leur empreinte carbone
les petits maraîchers sont donc
clairement visé mais auront-ils les
moyens de faire le saut vers
l'électricité dont les équipements sont
deux à trois fois plus coûteux ces deux
à trois fois plus cher qu'un équipement
conventionnel on peut s'imaginer là que
c'est difficilement ce serait
difficilement bout de quarante ou
cinquante mille dollars le pour ce
s'installer un système électrique
donc en ce moment et aucune un statut
pour les producteurs en serre de
chauffer les lectrices ce qu'ils font ce
parce qu'ils sont vraiment convaincu
même s'il affirme le pied maraîchers
correspond au profil visé une petite
ferme ou un système au mazout est déjà
en place qui servirait d'appoint en cas
de panne
la transition n'est pas pour demain tout
simplement parce que le courant
industriel qu'on appelle aussi courant
triphasé ne passe pas devant la ferme
comme pour de nombreux producteurs en
serre l'accès à l'électricité demeure le
frein principal est ce qu'on est
rentable pour hydro de monter deux
lignes sur 5 km pour se rendre ici pour
que nouvelle triphasé paulissen je pense
pas mais en tout cas c'est pour moi que
la réponse me
[Musique]
au cégep de victoriaville on forme les
maraîchers de demain ici on apprend tout
des semis à la récolte mais on apprend
aussi à gérer une entreprise
la production en serre est un pilier de
la formation ont peu avant 5 % notre
superficie qui est en soi mais qui vont
représenter 20 % de nos revenus et que
ces destructions s'amortir très
rapidement li ser permettent d'allonger
les saisons d'avoir des légumes plus tôt
au printemps et plus tard à l'automne
on va sortir beaucoup de kilos au mètre
carré en termes de légumes versus hanche
à rexton incontournable pour chauffer
une serre sous nos lattitudes nordiques
différentes sources d'énergie sont
présentés au futur maraîchers on va
parler de la biomasse on va parler aussi
du propane l'électricité aussi si la
source est pas loin
c'est toutes les possibilités qui
existent mais c'est certain c'est là le
coup finalement de l'installation
le coût d'utilisation qui va faire en
sorte qu'on re prendre une décision pour
cette nouvelle génération passionnés
d'agriculture le choix de
l'hydroélectricité une source d'énergie
propre pourrait tomber sous le sens
pourtant entre les idéaux et la réalité
il ya parfois le décalage
plus souvent qu'autrement sur les fermes
actuellement de ce type là ça va être
des systèmes de chauffage au propane
une source qui est viable et
relativement économique et le nouveau
tarif demandé à la régie de l'énergie ne
risque pas de changer la donne car sans
soutien adapté pour l'achat d'une
fournaise et l'installation de l'entrée
électrique
l'hydroélectricité demeure inabordable
c'est malheureux mais c'est souvent des
choix économiques qui vont douter
certaines décisions et d'entrepreneurs
l'entrepreneur c'est pour ça qu'on se
tourne et à mont tremblant c'est
exactement ce qui s'est produit
la ferme aux petits oignons emploie une
vingtaine de travailleurs locaux et
génère un chiffre d'affaires de 860
milles dollars avec à peine 4 hectares
en culture
c'est une ferme d'élite un modèle dans
le milieu quand on a démarré la ferme je
sortais de mes études en génie avec des
piles une vision de l'énergie une vision
de l'écologie puis je croyais que
l'électricité pouvait être une solution
pouvait le devenir pouvait le rester
donc j'ai cru dans investir dans
l'électricité faire une entrée l'écrit
pour chauffer mais ça l'électricité avec
une entrée électrique normal on peut
faire une seule mais au-delà de ça il
faut énormément de de gaudi
de risque françois renfield et
copropriétaire de la ferme avec
véronique bouchard cette année 900
familles sont abonnés à leur panier
c'est 300 de plus que l'an dernier en
2011 les deux entrepreneurs s'installe
de façon permanente dans les hautes
laurentides une région mieux connu pour
ses montagnes ses sports d'hiver que son
maraîchage en débarquant la venue
s'installer à mont tremblant les gens
nous décourager c'est pas une région
propice à la production de légumes
par contre l'accueil a été vraiment au
delà de nos espérances et c'est pour ça
aussi que l entreprise ont connu une
croissance qu'on n'avait pas prévu
rapidement les trois s'est reconstruite
au départ ne suffisent pas aujourd'hui
la ferme en compte 8 et pourrait encore
prendre de l'expansion
non on ne suit pas le cas de thomas
series aujourd'hui mais ce parce qu'on a
chauffé
dès le départ les deux agronome de
formation cherche une source d'énergie
renouvelable pour chauffer leur serre
[Musique]
pour nous ce terreau de question
d'utiliser a principalement aux
combustibles fossiles en back up
peut-être mais pas comme constitue
principal c'est une question de
cohérence en libye où on a des bâtiments
écologiques
on essaie d'avoir un mode de vie avec le
plus en harmonie avec avec notre
environnement donc c'est certain que
pour nous la source d'énergie que ces
serres leur élément crucial de notre
production mais oui c'est un enjeu qui
nous qui nous touche beaucoup le
seulement 2 % des superficies en serre
sont chauffés à l'hydroélectricité
c'était aussi le cas à l'époque quand
les deux entrepreneurs ont choisi cette
source d'énergie
comme on est sur une route principale
d'accès du court en trois phases donc
c'était une option que pour toutes les
femmes peuvent avoir et qui nous
apparaissait le écologique et qui selon
les calculs préliminaires semblaient
aussi ait économique
au départ on avait prévu chauffer nos
serres avec de l'électricité à environ
8.5 soul kilowattheure qui le prix que
normalement on paye en agricole c'était
l'entente que j'avais au début avec
hydro-québec le tarif domestiques
essentiellement d'entrée de jeu la
facture est salée mais les maraîchers
maintiennent le cap
un changement de compteur électrique en
2018 fait toutefois bondir la facture
résultat depuis deux ans le système
d'appoint au mazout qui devait pallier
les pannes d'électricité est utilisé
plus que jamais au québec on a la chance
d'avoir de grandes ressources de l'eau
puis des forêts qui sont deux énergies
renouvelables puisque est un peu
aberrant c'est que nous on utilise un
pétrole qui vient au mieux de notre
province
incapable d'obtenir des tarifs adéquat
la ferme aux petits oignons et donc en
transition vers un autre système de
chauffage
nous on est en affaires on doit chauffer
des serres et on veut agrandir mon sort
parce qu'on est à mont tremblant et les
gens aiment les tomates et les
concombres
donc quel autre source d'énergie serait
la plus durable et la plus
économiquement viable on est dans une
région forestière dont le chauffage à la
biomasse apparaît comme une solution
quand même intéressante le carbonneau
locale
le projet de transition vers la biomasse
est déjà bien entamée et la ferme est en
attente d'une subvention c'est des gros
projets des très gros projet pour nous
on parle de 350 mille dollars pour
seulement 800 ya du risque et qu'on
espère qu'à terme ça va fonctionner
puisque l'approvisionnement en biomasse
va rester fiable c'est un peu comme
l'électricité faut que
l'approvisionnement soit fiable que le
prix soit bombay a quand même c'était
certes cela autour des granules de bois
m
[Musique]
produire des aliments localement
favoriser notre économie en polluant le
moins possible voilà l'objectif du
gouvernement du québec
les tarifs préférentiels sont un premier
pas sur la voie qu'il faudra prendre tôt
ou tard les énergies fossiles on ne
reprochera un moment donné s'en éloigner
de se lancer avec l'électricité c'est
d'être des 10 eur puis à l'avant garde
ça freine l'investissement naissance à
tout faire mais il ya quand même des
économies substantielles avec une vision
à long terme
l'électricité reste quand même une
énergie la plus verte faune au québec on
devrait la considérer peut-être mieux
par le passé les producteurs en serre
ont déjà bénéficié de tarifs
préférentiels d'hydroélectricité dans
les années 80 le québec était un leader
dans l'éclairage dessert mais les tarifs
ont été abandonnés par la suite un
rendez vous manqué selon plusieurs
auquel on donne aujourd'hui une seconde
chance
donc pour nous il est trop tard c'est
pour les nouvelles fermes il faut que
les nouvelles fermes qui s'installe qui
se demande comment je vais choquer
nessakh qui se rajoutent les cris cité
dans l'éventail de solutions pour ça
faut un engagement fort de viser à long
terme pour un prix abordable surtout un
prix puis une garantie que ce prix là
vaut rester là nous présente ces des
tarifs préférentiels qui vont durer
combien de temps on le sait faux
[Musique]
les audiences sur les tarifs
préférentiels auront lieu devant la
régie de l'énergie début novembre
on s'attend donc à une décision au cours
des prochains mois